did youever think you
make Victory I know this life
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David value giv values
contagious this world are entrepreneurs
we get no value to hater how run homie
look what I become I'm the
[Music]
yeah okay so episode number
38338 uh we got home team here we got a
lot of things to cover one of the things
I watched last night is this weird movie
called Leave the World Behind it's a
story I'll read you the
plot the stories about America being hit
by a Cyber attack and other things
taking place that shuts down the power
grid in the US planes are crashing
Teslas are running into each other it's
a dark movie with a few lines and by the
way guess who is the executive producer
of this movie it's a couple you may
recognize these guys Michelle and Barack
Obama weird very weird very weird we
we'll talk about that because it reminds
me of a movie that went viral during
covid that everybody was talking about
weird
contd 10
years maybe maybe it's something that's
coming up here
soon um shout out to DeVito by the way
DeVito's agent is the best that the
Giants have you seen
freaking but have you met his agent have
you seen his agent we'll talk about that
maybe in a minute Nikki Haley leads
Biden by 17 and Trump by I form and
that's a Wall Street Journal poll bunch
of guys are endorsing her zalinski is
coming back here to be for some more
money I'm sorry race raise uh some more
money he's coming back we'll talk about
that Trump's got a big lead in Michigan
Trump tops the santis by 32 points uh
boys are struggling they can take
coaches tutors and thousands a month to
fix that parents are hiring coaches to
teach their boys what it is to be a boy
can you imagine what what a jacked up
place this is where boys forgot what it
is to be a boy I got into bit of a
debate at Dylan's game with this father
that just pulls up to me starts talking
to me about Destiny and Tate I'm like
dude what is the matter with you we had
the best debate for 10 minutes and I'm
talking to a guy about a movie to my
right he's like what the hell is going
on here this is it's totally fine MC
trying to keep up P mcdermid coach gives
a speech that is the weirdest speech you
will ever he a hear a football coach
give to his players in a locker room
saying imagine how
United the the the 911 the 9911 teamwork
that did the attack on World Trade
Center we have to have that level of
teamwork can you imagine that as a
motivational speech by the way just
saying it makes me feel uncomfortable I
can't believe he said that he said that
and then uh we'll talk about Barack
Obama's movie we'll talk about a couple
things here they're telling us we got to
mask up again if you haven't yet by the
way one of the things that was very
impressive out of all the stories what
you know you've made it when you say
things like you know uh I I don't need
church because my personal ethics are
enough and your name is fouchy oh yeah
the Doctor Who who by the way Pat he
even brags he's like yeah I have
security 24/7 because everybody knows
what I who I am and what I've done
personal ethics damn better don't know
China's cyber Army is invading us
Services we'll talk about that New
Hampshire man charged with threatening
to kill Vic ramas Swani ramaswami we did
an xace everybody was texting me saying
Pat you got to get on the crawling for
you with Elon Musk letting Alex Jones
back on I was there I said a few words
maybe we'll talk about that we should
Trump says he'll be a dictator day one
Biden Administration wants to forgive
nearly five billion five billion in
additional student loan dead and you got
to see this one line this one quote time
I'm will share with you guys Harvard
alumni outrage that the president was
accused of
plagiarizing American math scores hits
an all-time low on International level
exams and then a couple other things
here today's parents have to pay $3.4
million to fund the American dream for
themselves and their kids and maybe
we'll get into the math for buying a
home no longer works Realtors you may
want to skip that part having said that
before we get into these stories Rob
today's sponsor American Harford go go
ahead and play it
so look I've been in the financial
industry since 911 the day before 911
and I've owned stocks bonds mutual funds
real estate crypto gold you name it I've
owned it but the one thing that's very
important part of my portfolio all these
years is gold I love having a percentage
of my network in Gold that I have access
to in case of many different things
that's why we chose to work with our new
sponsor American Heartford gold if you
have retirement funds that you cannot
afford to lose American Harford gold
will ship physical gold or silver
directly to your door also if you have
retirement funds that you can't afford
to lose now is the time to call American
Harford gold a precious metal dealer you
can trust they have the finest products
amazing customer service and a buyback
commitment they've earned a five-star
rating from thousands of reviews and an
A+ from the Better Business Bureau tell
them I send you and they'll send you up
to $5,000 worth of free silver on your
first order so click on the link in the
description or call 866939 6984 again
6984 by the way I don't know if you know
or not for those that have been buying
uh gold Gold's been going up okay you
just reach an alltime high I think $2200
I want to say bitcoin's at what now
45,000 42 to 46 so anyways that's our
sponsor American hard for took a dump
yesterday to 41 after Elizabeth Warren
let's get right into it let's get right
into it you took a d what' you say
Bitcoin Bitcoin took a dump yesterday
took share stuff like that on a live
podcast when it's off I get it but Tom L
be too much got caught
in that's right so took the Tre out of
my I Ed the bathroom I love the fact
that tell story maybe anyways it's a
Sunday 2 3:00 they decide to hold this
uh um uh Twitter space Mario nafal maybe
I'm not saying the name right he does a
phenomenal job with this and he ends up
having uh uh he ends up having musk Tate
Alex Jones vivec
myself uh Gates a bunch of PE I'm
missing names a bunch of just think
about
murderers people my God and it was a
conversation about Alex Jones being back
on it was great and they were having a
discussion Elon started off by talking
about Sandy Hook and and VI rasani was
caught on a hot mik used in the bathroom
and the main guy hosting it says re
that's you you says oh I'm sorry guys
and then he feel yeah the best tweet I
think is by Matt Walsh who says now we
understand what they mean by a stream by
Twitter I thought that was very funny
but it was great it's you know the whole
good news is the right people are
finding each other Fighters are finding
each other and future looks bright it's
exciting to see what's going to be
taking place but uh this is exciting to
see Alex Jones coming back we'll get
into that story later I want to get into
the Barack Obama story oh yes Barack
Obama gave major feedback on the Leave
the World Behind script I watched this
movie last night I finished it at
12:30 and very weird movie a dark movie
okay Barack Obama the former US
president has expanded his
post-presidential activities by offering
input on Sam isma's script for Leave the
World Behind a Netflix movie ishal Saw
Barack Obama's perspective to enhance
the script's realism and by the way very
weird that the fact that they say this
because you'll hear some of the stuff
that's said in this movie is recounted
Obama's response saying I am writing
what I think is fiction for the most
part I'm trying to keep it as true true
to life as possible but I'm exaggerating
and dramatizing and to hear an ex
president say you're off by a few
details I thought I was off by a lot the
fact that he said scared the F out of me
and ex as executive producers of Leave
the World Behind Barack and Michelle
Obama provided valuable feedback on
character development and empathy
emphasizing their passion for the book
and their desire for a compelling
cinematic adaptation Vinnie all right so
and mind you guys we're going to go on a
little journey because I watched it
watch before you do yeah just I haven't
seen the movie Tom have you seen it okay
I set set the you pull up the plot pull
the plot the I'll spoil alert cuz we're
going to give away them if you don't if
you want to watch the movie don't listen
to any of this so once upon a time so
basically uh Julia Roberts Marshal Ali
Ethan Hawk so it's basically a film
about a Cyber attack uh by hackers on
America they also sent a uh uh drones go
by and they're dropping thousands I'm
talking about hundreds of thousands of
Flyers with a snake photo that that says
death to America okay on one side of the
coast on the other side of the coast
they had the same drones but they were
dropping stuff in Chinese and just from
different countries so you don't know
where it's coming from right it was an
allout attack using something that they
called the three-stage maneuver to
topple the government uh from within
that ended with bombs dropping on cities
on the White House and they had
radiation so the three-stage maneuver is
isolation they disable all
Communications and transportation making
people deaf dumb and paralyzed number
two was synchronized chaos Terror with
covert attack and disinformation with no
clear enemy nobody knows who the hell
it's coming from and then the third
stage is the cou d'a Civil War and
collapse but the key is it says third
stage happens on its own you don't need
to do anything you don't do it says
first phase is isolation then it
synchronized chaos which means it's
intentional but the third stage you
don't do anything it's Civil War and
collapse this program was known as the
most coste effective way to destabilize
a country yeah dude that's what they
said in the movie by the way yeah that's
the the the the actor
B he's the one that says it oh yeah he
says a lot of crazy stuff because tell
him why he knew this stuff because his
friend he kept saying he had a ve so in
the car dude I got goosebumbs right now
there's a scene where he's looking at
Ethan Hawk and he's like listen I have a
very powerful friend we always joke
around he always says that he goes to me
with these Elites and they tell him this
type of stuff and it's a cabal and it's
evil and and dude he got got gets quiet
and he goes this last time he didn't
respond he's his money manager he goes
he didn't respond and they were leaving
cuz they know they have a heads up that
this stuff is coming down the pipe so
I'm watching this Pat and I'm like wait
Barack why would an ex-president and his
wife produce something like this as if
they know something is happening right
and he paid what you said he played a
key role in the film he was Hands-On the
entire the entire film uh Sam is the guy
the the director said that um he was
there giving him real world feedback so
when this guy was doing stuff Barack was
like no no no that's not how this would
play out trust me this is how it would
play out also just a little a little
detour they had some backlash for for
what he did uh they said in the movie
about white people there's a scene where
Marshal Ali is laying in bed with his
daughter cuz they're staying in the
basement of this house and he said and
this is what the daughter says and I
quote I'm asking you to remember that if
the World falls apart trust should not
be doled out easily to anyone especially
white people so that's in there um uh by
the way there's another quote in the
movie ready for this a conspiracy theory
by way stay on that stay on that because
it says if something happens to the
world we shouldn't trust white people
yeah that's something I know you and Mom
would agree with me quote end quote the
girl says that to the dad while they're
in bed together this girl is probably 22
years old if something happens to the
world we shouldn't trust white people
that's something I know you and Mom
would agree with me keep going so it's
this is layered mind you Pat there's
also uh a bunch of why would you put
that in a random random and the entire
time Julia Roberts played is this angry
white girl who's in sales and
advertising and the girl asks asks her
why are you so angry all the time she
says because if you know what I know on
a daily basis I I life for living and
I'm doing this and I'm doing sales and
I'm meeting with people and marketing
I'm sitting there saying dude you
literally have been lying for a living
you're an actress what the hell you
talking about your job is to act okay so
you're talking we saw you in Pretty
Woman young lady that wasn't acting
though but go ahead yeah EXA yeah
exactly she was hot but um
so this is a quote from the movie a
conspiracy theory about a shadow group
of people running the world is far too
lazy of an explanation especially when
the truth is far scarier no one is in
control no one is pulling the strings uh
an event like this happens the best even
the most powerful people can hope for a
heads up now Pat this movie besides
having the cultist stuff they had the
son was wearing an obey shirt the
daughter had a NASA shirt uh in the
title you could see that there's a b a a
l in it there's a scene in the movie I'm
not being that guy it it is what it is
there's a 666 in in a in a triangle this
is called Product uh predictive
programming and let me explain something
to you do you remember we saw that video
of the Iranian lawmakers chanting death
to America then Tucker Carlson on his
showpad had the he said about the EMP
attack that's going to come if we get
into a war with Iran and then and Rob
can you get this video ready bro CLA
Schwab World economic Forum that demon
all right he's predicting a Cyber attack
he said and I quote theid 19
with respect would be seen as a small
disturbance in comparison this is him
warning us listen to this pay
insufficient attention to the
frightening scenario of a comprehensive
Cyber attack which would bring to a
complete hold to the power supply
Transportation Hospital services our
society as a
whole the k 19 Crisis crisis would be
seen
in this respect as a small
diser in comparison to a major Cyber
attack okay guess what and I'm almost
done this the predictive programming
they're letting you know it's coming
like the movie uh contagion with
covid-19 the girl went to Hong Kong it's
like how do they know and I people
always ask H why do the elites always
let us know what's coming down the pike
right they tell you through movies
through music what they're going to do
it's called and you guys can look this
up the revelation of the method they do
this to avoid Bad Karma I mean who who
would have thought you know evil would
have you know morals they put their true
intentions out there so nobody could
accuse them of not warning us of things
to come all right it's like when you
hear Bill Gates talking about
depopulating the Earth he does it uh and
they believe that uh when they tell us
this they will not face consequences in
1981 I dug a little deep p in 1981 uh
the CIA director William Casey said to
Ronald Reagan in the west wing and
there's a bunch of people that said he
said this he said and I quote we will
know our disinformation is complete when
everything the American public believes
is false this was an American spy CIA
guy uh and it's not like Pat when I talk
about this type of stuff guys that it's
not true this movie came out last week
guess what happened yesterday a massive
Cyber attack in the for in the United
States by China for our infrastructure
they hit Hawaii's Water Utility Systems
they hit a oil and gas pipeline and they
tried to take down the electrical Grid
in Texas and yesterday Rumble was
attacked Rumble Rumble got cyber
attacked yesterday and just a side noad
since I'm in this world of of people and
evil and all this type of stuff did you
see what happened at the Iowa capital
building yesterday these are these are
the type of people that take down Thomas
Jefferson statue but they had a satanic
demon displayed up there Rob can you
show that they they have a satanic D in
P I'm talking about C we have a keep
going down Rob this is actually it
scroll to the bottom they're not even
hiding any anymore guys they the keep
going keep going keep going keep going
keep going down Rob it's not there keep
going story continues press story
continue right there and go so and I'll
get into it so and it's not as if we we
come up with this type of stuff and
they're lying and yeah that that this is
on display at the Iowa capital state
building uh that and there it's the
satanic church and they're saying listen
we have rights too we could do it that's
the
goat owls and goats look at the pentag
on the CH so when we talk about this
type of stuff I always question Tom I
always question I'm like why would they
show it to us why did they do it this is
out in the open they're not hiding
they're giving us a heads up before it
comes out and it happened yesterday so
that I wouldn't be surprised if that's
the next I got to tell you this you know
for me the the movie as dumb as it was
okay I couldn't stand the movie it's so
boring horrible terrible the music is
Eerie the the the behavior of her and
the guy marriage the wife guy and the
daughter the stuff that like they're
presenting like it's normal
behavior and the line you know a
conspiracy theory of some Shadow
organization running the world is not
true a line set in the movie that a
former president was involved in the
script No One controls the strings
they're saying this in the movie Are you
supposed to believe that do you actually
believe No One controls the strings Rob
run a poll asking do you believe anyone
controls the strings yes or no then few
other things microwave weapons that
cause radiation this happened in Cuba
Kevin Bacon says it there's a scene in a
movie where he says cash may not mean
much when the government Falls by by the
way the even though that's a line in a
movie that is true though cash may not
mean much when the government Falls you
have to be aware that that there is some
credibility to that statement and
another line when the when the kid says
it when the when the father says it I
can barely do anything without my cell
phone and GPS I am a useless Man without
my cell phone says in the movie let me
read it again I can barely do anything
without my cell phone and GPS I'm a
useless Man without my cell phone and
there's a bunch of other things we made
a lot of enemies around the world maybe
what this means is they all teamed up
against us Kevin Bacon is saying it to
both of the guys that they're talking to
so that's an anti-am globalism message
this was a pure anti-america we caused
this this is the reason why this is
taking place it is a movie to trash
America it is a movie to manipulate
people watching it is a movie to get
people thinking and believing but if
there's one thing that I did believe
when it was done you know there's
different torture methods one of the
torture methods when they put you in the
in in in jail is this screeching sound
that they they make that stays on for a
couple days that you can't go to sleep
oh my God you know that that that sound
do you know what I'm talking about they
hurt your ears yeah they did you yes and
they you no matter what you do it's so
loud you so you can't it's like worse
than a baby crying in your ear oh it's
10 times wor the kid go ahead goe in the
movie they do this to the entire state
to the entire town and everybody hears
it and everybody collapses there's even
a scene where Julie Robert's chasing
after her daughter to find her the pain
is so bad she falls to her knees so the
pain was so excruciating that she
couldn't even chase after her daughter
to find her it cripples you it cripples
you and and and and one of one of the
bad reactions of that radiation that
that symol was that signal the son's
teeth just start falling out so they're
looking for a doctor that's why they go
to Kevin Baker and and then uh uh they
said I read I wrote this somewhere P
this the political C the political C uh
which is a foot they say which is why
the people in positions of Power are
letting a Civil War take root by
disrupting technology and feeding
disinformation and you said that third
stage it happens on its own so
everything all this stuff it's just
weird CLA Schwab all it's throughout the
history they warn us go they warn us
what's coming Pat because apparently in
religion Rob we talked about this before
they have to give you a heads up as it's
coming down the pike which is weird what
are you going to say Rob no there's a
there's a very interesting um episode
there was a TV show called The xfiles do
you guys remember that show 0s David du
do you ever hear of the spin-off show
The Lone Gunman no okay there was a TV
show that fox produced in 2001 it was
going to be a spin-off of some of the
people that fed molder and Scully
information about the xfiles uh there
the pilot episode aired March 4th of
2001 so this
is seven months before 911 the entire
episode predicted that a the government
would use a controlled drone airplane to
fly into the World Trade Center to then
launch I swear to God to launch a war in
the Middle East so I have it up here at
the xfiles but March 4th of 2001 that
comes out and then 6 months later 911
literally uh planes fly into the World
Trade Centers and then we go to war with
so am I am I am I crazy to say what I
say when I'm telling you it's called
predictive programming they let you know
what's coming and then when it happens
we have these moments where we go wait
what but here's a question though here's
a question okay Tom you remember the
only guy we ever brought on the podcast
twice in the same same month was a guy
named Peter p and he died afterwards
yeah weird he literally died afterwards
he was the electromagn pulse guy yeah he
was the guy that knew the most about
emps we bring him on he talks and he
talks about the fact that everybody
should own
a nuclear under underr bunker he was
sort of a Doomsday prepper type I
believe it dude but I tell you what the
the level of qualification on what this
guy had in his background when he spoke
you're listening was that interesting
you were fascinated I think you wanted
to say something Tom go for it no what I
was looking at here is
remember there's none of this is
surprising to me because this is all the
scop stuff uh and it's real scops is
real you you also can just go look at we
talk about it in our um our our
political discourse they say is accuse
the other side of doing exactly what you
are doing now right it's like oh you're
it's such as the um uh the Liberals were
accusing Republicans of using redlining
and redistricting to manipulate
elections you're manipulating elections
through redlighting redistricting and
denying people the right to vote by
create creating obstacles in the form of
identification other things that are
designed to do this so what all those
come out and then now we find out that
you know ballot harvesting we've got
videos of ballots being brought in you
know in in suitcases and buckets it's
real did it alter the whole election who
knows uh were there was there fraud
involved of course so it's accuse the
other side which you're exactly doing
now and also you know you you also I
think that's called the heelan dialectic
want to say don't ask me how I know that
holy crap very good oh wow stay in
school kids dial just got a configration
that one though Pat I'm very impressed
hang I want to know your point Tom I'm
waiting so the the point is here is this
all comes out to Prime the populace that
is the whole purpose of it when you look
at operation Mockingbird and all these
things in scops scops what you have to
do is you have to make it not surprising
M it says and also put yourself in a
position where you're offensive not
defensive so that's how you prime the
pump by letting people know saying
things out there so they're not as
surprised number one and then number two
you know the scop we're just talking
about elections accuse the other side of
what you're going to do and when you do
all this the population the populace is
somewhat somewhat numbed and somewhat um
yeah you know
incapacitated can I say can I say
something to do when when I mean I don't
know how many times I said this on this
podcast how much more is China
going to do cuz yesterday we had the
Cyber attack spy balloons over the place
covid-19 and then we just worship Gavin
Newsome brings these people brings Xi
Jinping to to California and they clean
the streets and they put the Chinese
flag it's like China is the let stay
let's stay on this let stay on this I
mean that's let's actually have a very
logical conversation okay so first of
all for those you know if you're
watching it's like oh here we go again
well listen this is not here we go again
if this movie was done by anybody nobody
would give a if this movie was done
by I don't know stepen Spielberg Ridley
Scott you know Steph Spielberg nobody
would give a yeah it's just another
movie I got it you know like World War Z
or Independence Day or whatever whatever
no no this is the former president who's
the executive producer of this movie
like let me put it this way Barack calls
you you're his friend he says hey I'm
thinking about investing into this movie
what is it about it's about what America
would look like if there was a cyber
warfare and how we would shut down the
entire system and control minds and
making sure we tell them that there is
nobody that controls the strings what
would you tell Obama as a friend who's
trying to go into movies the first time
what would you tell him maybe you would
say Brock you may want to skip this
movie bro you may want to skip this
movie and go to like a you know
biography about I don't know a you know
RGB or Ruther what's her name Ruth pader
Ginsburg RBG RBG or do a do like a movie
about a story of somebody something like
that no you choose to do this movie as a
former president that first of all
that's a little weird for me even as an
American to to to to tell a story like
that because the enemy is either sitting
there saying hey man thanks Brock that
was fantastic or the enemy sitting there
saying you're giving ideas or the you
just scared the out of the populace
FYI it was very believable nothing about
what I watch was unbelievable everything
about what I watch was very very
believable that sound the the brain
stimulation thing that simulation thing
that they do believable that whole
concept about cars electric cars all
going in the same direction because now
you control the satellite and they took
out the satellite believable the ship
coming nonstop to the what do you call
it to the to the beach and the kid is
like I think that ship is coming towards
us believable planes losing satellite
control communication crashing in the
middle of the ocean believable there
wasn't anything that you looked at and
you said this is unbelievable right so
as somebody like myself who was in a
military who was Middle Eastern and who
was in the insurance space you know what
all those three have in common paranoia
okay when you live in the Middle East
you're naturally what what if this
happens what if that happens what if
this happens what do you talk when
you're in the military if this happens
you got to do this you got to flank this
you got to B you got to okay what
happens when you're in Insurance
business you buy insurance because God
forbid you die what if this happens
bread R there everything is about
preparation so as much as we're having
this conversation here
together if you're married with kids I
actually would seriously encourage you
to have a serious conversation with your
friends and peers to see what you could
do because there was a scene where these
guys are driving around and the one guy
Kevin Bacon says something he says have
you guys gone to tson house whatever the
guy's name is have you guys gone to such
and such a house uh no why well I know
one of my buddies you know built a
nuclear bunker underneath it and he
built a bunker and you know I know who
did he never wanted to show it to me and
he never confirmed it but I know my
friend built that thing and if there's
anywhere for you guys to go that's the
place to go and the daughter goes there
accidentally she opens the store and she
goes in and she hits the switch the the
it's not even a switch like this like
this it's like a generator switch the
whole thing turns on and it's a nuclear
place under where the glass window is a
led to show light and show sky and show
this even though you're underground
right these are these are some things
financial planning health planning this
is why you do executive testing every
year time introduce me to that in ' 08 I
went to UCLA did my executive testing
you meet with nine doctors within nine
hours and find out everything about your
body sounds like I probably need to go
do an executive testing right now but I
did one about a year ago everything is
about preparation for the next year and
this movie made me think about that to
be honest and can can I add one thing go
so you know me I'm pretty skeptical
about you know just generic stuff like
this but I will say this um in
2015 um this was actually at a nalba
type meeting back in the day they had a
guest speaker it was Ted Copple do you
remember who Ted C is yeah he used to do
the ABC 11:30
news
Ted considered one of the most what
respected journalists of all time Rob up
a picture of Ted CPP all you got to do
is hit images buddy um Ted coupple Dan
Rather you know the this type of guy
you've seen him you know his face and at
the time this was at the height of the
2016 election Trump Hillary
Clinton and obviously all the news was
about build the wall build the wall
build the wall and he goes you know I'm
not so concerned about the wall I'm
concerned about U the electric git
situation and cyber attacks and this is
before it became sort
of you know present day conversation of
where we're at as part of the the Norman
culture right going on right now but he
started warning of these electric git
attacks okay and nobody really had heard
this type of speech especially from
respected journalists at this point so
he starts basically say here to go Ted
coplon lights out a Cyber attack a
nation unprepared this is 2015 Miami
book fair so it was right around the
time probably wrote a book about this
and it made me aware holy this and
he basically went into great detail of
what would happen so what my My ultimate
point is this this has been pervasive in
in the culture for almost 8 10 years now
at this point not far-fetched not
unbelievable certainly something that
we're hoping the military is on top of
the scariest thing is what Pat pointed
out why did Barack Obama cosign
something like this weird and his quote
and his quote was this I'm writing what
I think is fiction for the most part I'm
trying to keep keep it as true to life
as possible but I'm exaggerating and
dramatizing so it's just interesting
that he put his name behind something
and and and P but think about it I don't
want to spend any more time 30 seconds
we're moving on to the next but and he
made a great point there was a they put
it in movies and music and all that
stuff Rob said the thing about 911
contagion with covid and then bro do you
understand how volatile our power grid
is Pat think think about this George
Colin talked about it if electricity
shut off here in the United States can
you imagine look what happens when a
when a light intersection light shuts
off nobody knows what the hell to do God
forbid our po power goes down bro it's a
rat let's just hope that we're utilizing
it to someone to the enemy before they
use it utilize it on us guys not listen
let me tell you what life is better off
the way you live it's not let's just say
the power grid goes out out okay I'm
telling you it's going to happen I know
I just don't know when it's going to
happen meaning is it going to be in 2024
during election year CU they're scared
shitless that Trump could actually win
is it going to be 20 is it going to be
next 5 years 10 years 15 years I believe
it's going to happen you best just do
whatever you can to be ready for it some
people are maybe saying well I don't
have the kind of money you guys got the
money D this isn't about money there's
ways of preparing in different ways
based on the kind of resources you get
you have to figure out what level of
resource like if we are a small country
and we don't have the kind of money that
China's got or other people have we have
to use our resources to create our own
weapons even if we're a small little
country you have to think about it that
way you're a startup country protect
your family how do you do it you have to
do a little bit of research little bit
of studying for yourself and if to find
out if that were to happen do you have a
small generator do you have certain
things set aside what method of payment
will you use if you don't have any cash
or if you don't have what other things
do you have to protect your family I do
believe it is something worth talking
about with your family to be prepared
for this cuz I think something like this
going to happen next 5 10 15 20 years
and by the way I do believe it's going
to be worse than Co because at least
with Co you can stay
home and still communicate with others
with this you stay home your internet
security gate lights it's Mayhem
everything's gone so what do you do you
just got to be prepared for it and if it
doesn't happen better you know if if it
never happens awesome but at at least
you were prepared for worst case
scenario my concern is how deep is our
mil like you think Barack you think Joe
Biden's military is ready for this hell
no I have no idea but I tell you the
next president whoever it is this has
got to be a topic of discussion to make
some major investments into this to make
sure the American people are protected
okay let's go to the next story next
story we got Tom we're going to go talk
about what happened with Harvard and a
pen uh president on last week being
grilled um which was the most vied what
was it Congressional hearing we've ever
had so pen president board chair resigns
after feror after F over comments on
campus anti-Semitism so she resigned
then other things come out let me see
this one here former president Liz mcel
last week made a very unfortunate
misstep consistent with what of two PE
University leaders sitting alongside her
after 5 hours of aggressive questioning
before a congressional committee stated
Scott elbach the chairman of the
University of P following that became
clear that her position was no longer
tenable and she and I concurrently
decided that it was time for her to exit
representative stepanic applauded Mill's
resignation saying one down two to go
this is only the beginning of addressing
the pervasive Rod of anti-Semitism that
has destroyed the most prestigious
higher education institutions and and a
couple other things came out with her
plagiarizing the Harvard alumni
president gay Tom I'll read that and
I'll just turn it over to you from
there Harvard alumni outrage after
president accused of plagiarizing
desertion okay Harvard lumni demanded an
investigation into plagiarism
allegations against School president
Claudine gay with Christopher rufo and
Christopher brunette accusing of verbais
plagiarism as they revealed instances of
lifting texts from AC other academics as
stated in their report report first gay
lifts an entire paragraph nearly verbais
from Lawrence Bobo and Franklin Gillum
great last name race sociopath political
participation and black empowerment
while passing it off as her own
paraphrase and language the researchers
emphasize that such plagiarism violates
Harvard owner Honor Code potentially
leading to disciplinary action Harvard's
Honor Code specifies that students who
submit work not their own or failed to
attributed sources can face disciplinary
measures including potential withdrawal
from college so one one of the three
resigns the other one's getting caught
plagiarizing Tom what do you think is
going to end up happening here so let's
let's run down the list let's take the
easy one first Penn Wall Street Journal
today the Wall Street freaking Journal
today says blames wealth Rich for the
Miguel departure that they had been on
her back for weeks and there had been um
you know you know a dialogue that was
getting very tense between them wait a
minute so how did the journal what is
the journal saying so pen they're trying
to spin it already that well you know
it's it's it's these dog on Rich Oh you
mean the ones that go to Wharton that
are funding your endowment those dog on
Rich so Penn you know Miguel resigns the
pressure was on from the alumni people
from Wharton it all came to a head she
said what she said she was wrong and
they fired her so it seems like what
happened at Penn was what should have
happened after the Congressional um
investig Congressional hearing where she
said what she said and that was trying
to be spun that oh well you know it was
the rich that did it and they've been
looking they've been trying to get her
for weeks right BS you're just trying to
put a spin on it then at Harvard
Harvard's the one that is actually more
complicated but easier it gets summed up
this the woke mob including the board at
Harvard the trustees at Harvard have
Protected Their Own it's pure hypocrisy
they Protected Their Own they and they
see this a noble fight there are
Billboards out there right next to
Harvard calling for her resignation
there are alumni sending letters and
posting on X very eloquent well
researched statements saying calling for
her dismissal and rufo presented a
beautiful dissertation on not beautiful
meaning well put together dissertation
on the plagiarism that happened in her
own uh scholarly articles she presented
herself for president so if this had
been a white male this this person's
gone this would already be over but
Harvard has protected the the trustees
in the board are protecting their person
and they see this as a noble fight you
have to understand what's going on here
the trustees in the board of Harvard are
taking her side because they see it as a
fight against the ones that are not
completely light lined up with their
woke agenda that's the only reason
they're defending her they are defending
one of their own tribe one of their own
mob and that's what they've done and
last night they expressed support for
her and said that she would not be
resigning and she said I'm not resigning
this happened very late last night there
were apparently meetings of the board
that went on yesterday and yesterday
evening so they've come out and said
this alumni this morning were freaking
out because the executive committee of
the Alumni Association so think of that
as like the board not all the members
just the board they came out and said
hey the Board of Trustees needs to come
out and make a positive statement of
support for her and keep her and there
were people like Bill Amman that said
wait a minute I'm a prominent alumni I
wasn't called they didn't pull the
alumni the Alumni Association executive
committee acted alone without really
getting the consensus of the alumni
because there was no consensus the
alumni are calling for her resignation
so it sums up at Harvard is the woke mob
protect itself but but okay besides the
backlash from what she they said or they
didn't say at the hearing time how bad
is this going to be for the future of
Harvard for obviously anybody Jewish
trying to go to this school but how
what's the like long longterm for her
staying there going to look like for
well I think what you have to see is
look at what is Harvard Harvard is not a
college Harvard is an association of of
elite woke individuals and their
children that are going to the school
and here's what I mean by that if you
take a look at at there's very
interesting you're not the customer and
they're okay losing you oh wow they're
okay losing your kids they're okay
losing his kids they're okay losing
everybody's kids exactly they're okay
with that wow and by the way you should
there was there is a graph that came out
I don't know if you can find it Rob
about grade compression that went on at
Harvard and there's a chart that came
out this past week that showed that the
average grade GPA was creeping up I
think it it think it was from Charter CH
h a r t r Charter did the thing on
Harvard grade compression and it's a
shocking chart that shows you that the
median grade given out now Pat is 3.8
median 3.8 means if you come to Har how
dare we give you a c and upset the woke
customer and so it is it's it's
horrifying so they they have ceased to
be I actually love the fact that they
took this position you know why I love
the fact that the board took this
position let me tell you why the board
took this position in this situation pen
one in this situation pen one because
you you can you can hire somebody for
example you can hire somebody in a
company and how much background can
you do on the person do you know if the
person's a serial killer no no do you
know if the P this person likes young
boys no do you know if this person has
certain porn habits you don't know about
no do you know if this person you don't
know this stuff right you hire them but
then imagine you hire them and that
comes out and then you don't fire them
if the board fires them what the company
is telling you is we don't stand for
that but if you hire them and the board
keeps them what the company is saying is
we stand for that so in this situation
Penn is saying uh-uh we don't stand for
what she just did Harvard is saying
uhhuh we do stand for what gay did wow
so Harvard lost big time okay parents if
you're thinking about putting your kids
in Harvard you may want to think
twice bad decision after bad decision
after bad decision you know there's a
school locally here you know know what
the school is I went to the school's uh
uh uh what do you call it interview for
my kids the high school you mean yeah
it's not a high school it's K through 12
K okay yeah so I went to the school and
we sat down with them it's the premier
School in all of Florida okay 50 Grand
year some number like that if you're on
the area you know exactly what I'm
talking about and I asked the question
I'm like so uh what is the school's top
priority with all the different issues
going on worldwide what would you say is
the top issues that you guys want to
educate the kids on oh number one is
climate change okay fantastic what else
two e equity and inclusive and all this
stff okay what how do you feel about
capitalism well what do you mean by that
I said how do you feel about capitalism
uh are you a trump voter I said they
asked you that I said the fact that I'm
telling you capitalism you think I'm a
trump voter because I said capitalism
what does capitalism have to do with
being a trump voter that's how you
categorize it so I said what do you feel
about well we like to teach um
capitalism and so socialism and
communism the pros and cons of it and we
let the kids decide I said said wait a
minute you the pros and cons of come
yeah we like to teach all of them and
let the kids decide I'm like how much
more market research do you need to you
real to realize this doesn't work right
this killed a lot of people what's the
moral of the
story you got to be asking those
questions you got to be protective with
your kids if you can't afford to put
your kids in private school you have to
be involved uh to know what they're
going through what they're dealing with
what they're teaching and what they're
being talked to because in a time like
this schools like this are showing you
their true colors and parents if you
send your kids there knowing what they
stand for just because you want to brck
to your sister your brother your cousins
that your kid went to Harvard you could
potentially lose your kids for 10 to 20
years to some pathetic ideology yeah let
me give you a little extra perspective
on pen because uh this whole
situation we're kind of coming in on on
the ninth ending and being yeah that's
what happened in the game but there's
been a whole buildup to what's going on
specifically at Penn who basically they
were the one University that their
president stepped down so this has been
building up for years they've been on a
collision course for
basically five years culminating with
the sort of the step down of what's her
name again Liz McGill who stepped down
as the president yes so let me go back
in history she's still a 10year
professor by the way she goes back to
the law school
so the just to kind of paint a picture
that's been sort of the progressive woke
left leaning universities we understand
that with their sort of appeasement of
radicalism that's been sort of
culminating in these academic echo
chamers on the left side on the right
side you have traditionally conservative
capitalist businessmen who are on the
Board of Trustees who are basically uh
donating hundreds of millions of dollars
so sort of funding this operation
especially in Wharton you'll be familiar
with this company's name Apollo Global
Management it's run by a guy the CEO
Mark Rowan okay familiar with that name
then you also have um Ross Stevens he's
the guy that end up withdrawing a100
million from pen all right so here's
what's going on so this Collision Course
has been a brewing we're we're we're
seeing what happened with the
Congressional hearing let's go back a
few years from now do you remember the
name Leah
Thomas who was that the the swimmer she
was the swimmer he was the swimmer
whatever they were the swimmer exactly
so what school did he she they go
toen state so what no not Penn State
brother oh my bad my bad pen my bad big
difference no not ped State exactly not
the ni Lions these guys right here God
she
is them was was the swimmer that was a
trans swimmer now here's what happened
this was I believe in 2020
2021 she was going through her trans
situation gender identity we all
understand that Vinnie you all right
brother yeah cuz he says I'm sorry cuz
he points he goes she's wearing a value
shirt and look at that face on they are
wearing a value tment shirt Vinnie have
a respect for he they them but here's
what happened at the
time they yeah her won this big swim
meet yeah what happens then Penn
University nominates her to the NCAA as
woman athlete of the Year oh weird so
all the trustees all the boards
conservative thinking capitalists are
like all right y'all we're going a
little too far with this is the face of
our brand yeah female Thomas so if you
remember that so she becomes this
nominee for NCAA Woman of the Year
nominated by Penn okay the trustee the
Board of Trustees they're all going what
the is going on here right now fast
forward to this past summer prior to the
October 7th Hamas attack the Palestinian
groups on campus were basically
organized this summer River to the Sea
Revival ideology type thing the board
Apollo Mark Rowan the rest of the crew
is like yeah not the best look for the
school people are basically going back
and forth on this they try to sort of
stop and appease whatever they're having
all these
debates boom October 7th happens boom
anti-Semitism happens boom she steps
down but there's been a track record
that's been basically awaiting this
Collision Course and that's why there's
no surprise that she stepped down Apollo
is the Leon black guy that gave a half a
billion dollars to for estate planning
half a billion
dollar oh that's right this has been ISM
for a while Rob can you go back to the
Harvard grade chart be on black there
you go go back to the Harvard grade
chart real quick take a look at this
look at what happened in the late 60s a
sharp rise in grades given by Harvard in
1960s to help students avoid the
military draft that was Vietnam now I'm
not saying Vietnam was a good War right
he says I as a six-year-old remember a
Vietnam funeral it was a bad War it was
a bad thing and a lot of people died but
what did was well we can't have our kids
going in there and look what they did
the GPA to help them avoid the draft
it's called a academic deferment so they
get the academic deferment put point is
Harvard has been activist going back to
the 1960s and you see the grade
compression here what's going on there
so their lack of authenticity has gone
way back and there have been things
Brewing below the surface and so to see
the three presidents come out there
these presidents are not outliers and to
cut the head off the snake it's a Hydra
it grows eight more that's exactly what
you're going to see with the ivy league
which is why the ivy league has come out
and say well we're all kind of nuts how
can we get rid of our Harvard president
because we all feel the same you know
what Deal With the flak deal with the
aftermath let's let's let's get behind
her regardless of the Billboards
regardless of the alumni regardless of
people saying they're not donating
anymore we don't care there's another
side to this right the other side so
people say why would you care Pat why
would you care wouldn't you care if 10
million 100 million people stop giving
you money no and I'll tell you why
because they were just given money in
the in Biden for giving student loans
how because they can charge whatever
tuition they want and the poor kids that
end up saddled with it get
forgiven by members of of Biden's
cabinet that recommend that you should
do the student loan forgiveness that
went to freaking Harvard so Harvard
Harvard's perfect they're like Vinnie
you're going to pay 5050 Grand a year to
go to school here I am well we'll give
you uh we'll give you student Lo we'll
give you academic aid for 25 of it but
you still got to pay 25 mhm you get a
student loan 25 a year comes to Harvard
they get paid right they're paid y
you're saddled don't worry a couple of
our guys will be in a presidential
cabinet someday and we'll just forgive
your loans Harvard gets it do you see
the cycle check this out cycle of Life
Biden Administration on Wednesday
announced an additional $4.8 billion on
student student loan debt relief
affected more than 80,000 borrowers the
announcement brings a total uh approved
debt cancellation by Biden
Administration to $132 billion for more
than 3.6 million Americans before
President B took office it was virtually
impossible for eligible borrow borrowers
to access to access the student debt
relief they rightfully earned student
debt relief they rightfully earned what
do you mean they rightfully earned Tom
said that earlier the hell US Secretary
of Education Miguel Cardona said the
data released today once again make
clear that the Biden Harris
administration's Relentless effort to
fix the broken student loan system are
paying off in a big way this level of
debt relief is unparalleled and we have
no intention of slowing down so what is
debt relief so first of all who's
responsible for it why why are schools
charging as much as they're charging why
are you not putting this on schools
schools are sitting there saying keep
doing dead relief we got our money we
don't give a we got our money we
don't care we don't care we don't care
do as much as you want to do this we're
totally fine with that and you're
teaching kids to be bailed out at a
young age they chose to go to college
nobody told them to go to college you
your Administration has sold the idea of
being successful is going to college
great so they go to college they borrow
the money now you're saying they
rightfully earned the debt relief
eligible borrowers what what they
rightfully earned eligible you know uh
uh what do you call it
uh uh debt relief they rightfully earn I
think it's insane what's going on but
colleges are sitting there celebrating
saying that $4.8 billion is coming to us
keep doing more of it anyways let's go
to the next story here
with what fouchi just said and then I
got a couple other stories we'll get
into as well even narcis narus didn't
love himself this much okay this is a
daily wire story um this much foui
doesn't need Church his personal ethics
are
I mean that's like a priest speaking
right there let's see here all right Dr
Anthony fi the former by the way there's
a video for this if you do have it if
you know how long the video is he's
explaining this right Anno to watch BR
it's a minute so annoying go ahead play
this clip what a what a I mean he's a
dirt bag you have to realize in America
he's Pope to many they used he's the
he's the pope of the health industry in
California I'm not joking you know those
those signs that say like go by people
in California when I left had him like
he was going for like he was the
president in the United States where
they worship I think I think liberals
moving forward need to call him Pope
fouchi pop go go and play this clip by
Pope fouchi pop of poke staring Chapel
where Chris and I were that's you
married right yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
beautiful yeah it's really nice at
security in the back you don't practice
anymore do you don't
why ah a number of complicated reasons
go on we have a whole
Corridor demon you know who he laughs
like puzzle right
you know that one priest that got caught
in the Jet and he laughs when the lady
comes and says the jet you bought from
Tyler Perry do you know who I'm talking
about do you know you've seen this
Copeland go back and do that laugh again
go back 10 seconds go go back a little
bit more little bit more back go back go
back go back go back detail okay press
play watch this
laugh a number of complicated reasons go
on we have a whole
Corridor oh my God first of all I I
think my own personal ethics on life are
I think enough to keep me going on the
right path and I think that the there
are enough negative aspects about the
organizational
church that you were very well aware of
I I'm not against it I identify myself
as a Catholic I was raised I was
baptized I was confirmed I was married
in the church my children were baptized
in the church but as far as practicing
it it seems almost like a pro forer
thing pause it right there before that
music you know what you know what I'm
you know you know what he should have
she should have said so you mean you
don't go to church anymore cuz when you
walk in your feet catch on fire cuz you
are a de that guy Pat the damage that
he's done from did you did you read the
the fouchy book uh Tom it's scary the
real Dr fouchy the that he's done
and what he's done to this country
because of Co and the lockdowns and you
know we had to listen to what the hell
he said the damn the lying the where a
mask don't wear a mask wear four five
mask he's a a artist bureaucrat
who's so protected do you see his
security detail he has like Secret
Service people guarding his ass because
he knows who he is and he knows what
he's done and the people like look look
just look at his face bro I'm telling
you he looks like Copeland by the way
hold that picture and go on a different
page and type in Copeland and then and
then look at the pictures of them they
they look like they're cousins but
Kenneth Copeland is way creepier looking
this guy's creepy but Adam you don't
agree with choose a different picture
though not a picture like that choose a
different picture just put him right he
he's science he's science he's this he
doesn't go to church go to Fouch go to
Fouch go right next to him yeah I mean
without the eyes yeah it's him but it's
like The Audacity Of Ju Just I just
still seeing him the eyes don't lie
Chico yeah I just I just don't respect
this gu I I am never surprised when bad
people do bad things I'm never surprised
but but Tom you never even heard of him
doing bad things until Co was like the
the final we know yeah we know you walk
down the street you don't know what bad
things any number of people are doing
but but think about it why would he need
this type of security why why do you
think he has like presidential security
because he knows what the hell he's done
Tom he knows not Vinnie Vinnie Vinnie
turn it from 11 to 9 for a second of
course he needs security he's pissed off
half the Free World who are waking up to
what has happened it doesn't surprise me
that bad people do bad things it
surprises me when occasionally a bad
person does a good thing that's what
surprises me it doesn't surprise me at
all and it doesn't surprise me to look
back at it and to hear him referring to
Catholicism like the kns like the kaanas
club that he happens to attend in town
and he talks about you know practicing
and he doesn't practice does that
surprise you that he's not a practicing
man of faith that doesn't surprise me
I'll tell you what I care he's capable
of doing this with not being a practic
evil people doing evil but does it does
it piss you off it doesn't piss you off
when evil people do evil things does
upset me it upsets me but it doesn't
surprise me we all need a savior we all
need to repent and it does not surprise
me when he does it but I get very upset
about it but I direct my energy from a
moment of being upset to a moment of
moving forward like Pat knows I'm
dedicated education in future what can I
do about it how can I do it I'm a
teacher at heart how can I help that
situation I don't know what I can do in
medical about fouchy except make sure
that I'm that's what this is
about what what you're going to Tom is
you're going pure to let's move on with
the story if we're doing a story want to
get your opinion on the story I we all
agree that we got to move on and build
our own life yep what I'm saying here is
here's a man who's got influence over
our kids and our youth in America and
he's making decisions that I would much
rather have a person fear the lord fear
God fear a bad decision that you are
hurting his people that I know he's
going to have a little bit of conscience
to make a better decision for a populace
that the amount of influence you have
for you to be like dude cuz you know
when you're deep down inside by yourself
praying here's what happens say you're
about to make a selfish decision okay
right now one of our
guys in a company just keeps making
selfish decisions after selfish
decisions after selfish decisions this
is three years in a row okay hey he'll
move somewhere I'm not moving there hey
I'm going to do this now hey pay me this
hey pay me that just like coming from a
very selfish place and he's blinded by
his decisions on what he's doing right
and he thinks he's making the best
decisions every time I ask myself who do
you talk to at night when you're praying
about a decision you make who who do you
fear do you not fear God do you not fear
something I would much rather have
somebody that's making decisions on my
health on Politics on NIH any of that
stuff where you're sitting there saying
I know what these politicians want me to
do but am I doing the right thing here
is this the right thing we're doing for
kids for parents we've only had N9 or 11
months of testing on vaccines does my
conscious make me feel good at night
before I go to sleep to say kids under
the age of two now need to take the
vaccine how the hell do you know if
that's going to affect That Someone's
Child no man that's so I that concerns
me when there's a leader with high-end
decisions being made by the way I don't
care if he's a Jew I don't care if he's
a Morman I don't care if he's a
Christian I don't care if he's a
Catholic I don't care what he is I just
care the fact that he fears a higher
power that you make a bad decision
there's going to be consequences when a
man doesn't have that level of fear
guess what that man's going to do is
entire life Reckless decisions because
it's all about who himself he's telling
you his personal ethics so guess who's
the only person he doesn't want to
disappoint himself himself no problem
I'm going to be okay disappointing
myself every once in a while no so you
you have to have a certain level of you
know uh fear that you have for the man
upstairs that prevents you from making
some bad decisions and for me the fact
that a man with this level of power is
relying on his own ethics
he's essentially becoming his own God
like in his world he is God and that's a
concern to me of course we're all going
to move on of course we got to build our
our life of course we got to do this
stuff but we got to be looking a little
bit more in in examples being given from
the top that men fear the the the
biggest Factor this is not a religion
debate let's set the religion debate
aside you're a Jew I'm a Christian Rob
what are you rob Presbyterian
Presbyterian Tom non-denominational and
I'm assuming you're also
non-denominational CHR yeah so okay but
we got friends here that are different
things all this other stuff do you know
the the benefits of a man a boy a girl a
woman a leader a general a president a
CEO an executive fearing a higher power
do you know how good that is for society
when men fear a higher power do you know
that level of fear now I don't mean from
the standpoint of uh the other day it's
so funny uh Kelly and Brandon Kelly
brings up data to me which is pretty
fascinating which countries pray the
most and you know what correlation she
found countries with the lowest life
expectancy the people that pray the most
countries with the highest level of life
expectancy they pray the least except
for America we are one of the only ones
that prays the most let me that data one
more time countries with the lowest life
expectance you're only Liv at 55 the
average person dies at 60 these are a
lot of Nations Muslim nations Nigeria
you know um you know you'll see that
they it's a lot of Nations that believe
in they're not Christian nations they're
you know different kind of Nations but
they pray the most to have the lowest
life expectancy a lot of countries that
you live to 80 82 83 they don't do a lot
of praying because they they're what
they're themselves right I I prefer a
person at the top running anything no
matter what happens when they go to
sleep by themselves they fear a higher
power that is beneficial to everybody in
that Society in that Community I believe
thate I agree I agree too so anyways we
can get to the next story here unless if
you wanted to lead us and pray I just
for if you want to I do father Adam here
Adam thank you guys join hands I will
say there is a difference between
organized religion and belief in a
higher power I know plenty of people
that don't go to Temple don't go to
church don't go to the mosque but they
do believe in something bigger than
themselves I think that is the most
important thing not that I'm defending
fouchy on this and he'll have his his
his day in in court or in uh the Pearly
Gates whatever it is I'm not here to
I'll Never See Court to cast judgment on
him but he did say I do consider myself
a Catholic I'm just no longer a member
of an organized religion I get it to me
honestly fouchy will he ever be held
accountable for whatever crimes zero
okay that's what pisses me off Trump had
a chance to fire him he didn't do it
Biden had a chance to relieve him of his
position obviously he didn't do it but
I'll Circle back to the number one thing
hold China accountable and they can't
what are we doing with that that's where
I'm and by the way China took you you
know the religion in China China zero
religion they don't they don't have a
belief in God no they believe they
believe in they believe State the
government they believe in the state and
we always come back to what you were
saying it's it's and you're right Adam
the zero accountability but the damage
that that little rat has done to the
people because think about all the
people that believed and took the
vaccine and now they're suffering and
he's walking around with security and
nothing will ever happen with him I can
be pissed off about that that drives me
bananas correction Pope fouchy moving
for I apologize do that I apologize R
does he get one of those cool white
coats big I can see him in one by the
way I can see rat all right next month
let's go into um boys are struggling it
takes it can take coaches tutors and
thousands a month to fix that this is a
Wall Street Journal story this is not a
spoof of a story they're talking about
boys are losing their identity so Middle
School boys are increasingly seeking
private tutoring Services focused on
improving personal organization skills
with 70% of terresa labovich clientele
being male parents are willing to pay
starting $500 a month to help their sons
become more motivated and organized for
success in high school and on
educational experts suggest that boys
have struggled to regain their
motivation after the pandemic compounded
by the distractions of laptops and
devices both in schools and at home
strategies combat that include enforcing
phone-free study environments to improve
focus boys academic challenges
exasperated by the pandemic include
declining test scores particularly in
reading and math as well as lower high
school graduating rates amongst the
girls Rob can you pull up that one tweet
I put up with are Matt scores what it
looks like if you just go to my there
you go if you just go there I think it's
the most recent tweet right there if you
click on that look at these numbers here
by the way this is Trends in American
mathematics reading and Sciences just
click on the chart forget about there
you go okay look at this guys from 2003
to today look at math look at reading
look at science constant
decline in our test scores on average
time you follow these things very
closely one what do you think's
Happening Here With Boys I know Kim is
fantastic with boys she's incredible
with our oldest son the relationship
they have is very unique they've had it
like that for many years what do you
think is the cause for boys being the
way they are today and two what do you
think about when you see these scores
being the lowest in a long time well
let's let's flip it over real quick and
I'll do the the second first um so the
scores that are going on here uh have a
direct correlation with uh um basically
digital distraction if you go take a
look at the iPhone internet and things
like this digital distraction is causing
you know um shortening uh attention
spans because they're snacking they it's
like look at Tik Tok bang bang bang bang
bang bang bang you go through all those
videos so the focus and concentration in
America's youth is going down and the
effectiveness of the schools is not
there and it's almost like the
Department of Education wants to create
a generation of people that relying on
the government then there's
that excuse me so that's the first part
digital distraction a lack of focus and
concentration and poor teaching leads to
this now the other side of it now you
compound that with boys
boys are naturally assertive and
confident it is a natural thing in boys
to be assertive and confident and kids
that that shrink back the parents are
looking at it and saying you know what
he's he's really not being like a guy
being a guy is there's an assertiveness
there's a confidence lead your family I
mean we're wired to go out and kill and
bring bring home the meat for if if you
think about that you know how we've how
we've developed through you know through
history that's what we do and the two
things here that are that are destroying
that is basically the way education is
being you know uh executed is poor and
the lack of focus and concentration and
now you create this nebulous environment
in school and a kid who is a male that's
assertive and confident actually faces
headwinds of feedback Pat you take your
kid in a school today if you're I don't
mean a kid that's disruptive or won't
listen I'm just talking about a natural
assertive confident boy and and he faces
headwinds of perception hey don't hey
Easy Does It Easy Does It And so now
parents are saying hey I I don't think
it's bad that he wants to play sports
assertive confident I don't think it's
bad he wants to be the team captain I
don't think it bad that he wants to lead
that's his natural male wiring that you
have kind of been short circuiting
against it so we've had all the social
short circuiting at the same time you
know the basically development
educationally has been going down
because of digital distraction and the
schools lowering standards and that's
the two thrusts and and notice how and
how fouchy found his way back into this
story the 2000 the pandemic drop is the
steepest with these ridiculous lockdowns
I did different it's funny that we moved
on to another store that was an
accelerate but it was already on its way
no already on it way but an accelerant
because of the lockdown and the stuff
that they did to children I think is
this is a story that I've actually been
following very closely U being that you
know on the show The SAU cast that I do
Finance romance role of a man role of a
woman who pays what's going on who's
dating who's getting laid where women
who's dating all where does money come
into all this and it sort of coalesced
into basically what is going
on between men and women today and it's
very interesting what's been going on so
you hear you know the song back in the
day I believe the children of the future
the children are the future but over the
last couple decades what have we heard
continually come from sort of the
modern-day matriarchy is that the female
is future or Beyonce's famous song who
runs the world girls okay and basically
the demise of the patriarchy right and
tearing down the patriarchy and if you
ever saw the movie Barbie that just came
out uh I counted the P the word
patriarchy was said 12 times okay uh 13
times if you want to give them a Baker's
Dozen um just for good measure but
there's something going on where they're
basically saying Hey listen guys you've
done enough especially young white men
white men in general thanks for all your
efforts the ladies got it from here but
what we know I mean you when you look at
the whole stats about single mothers and
and kids with single parents that the
best situation for a kid is is when
they're raised in a two parent household
or nuclear family um but if you just
take away the mother and just the father
is raising the kid what are the results
show at basically zero difference
meaning a father will do just as good of
a job very important raising a kid boy
or girl just the same as it is a two
parent household did you hear this okay
a single father raising kids boys gets
the same kind of results with the boy Bo
as the boy would get with Mom and Dad in
the household a single mother raising a
boy without a father does not get the
same because there's no because there's
no male there's no man in the house it's
what they call baby mama culture or
single single mother single father
households do vastly better than a
single mother here's the real reason's
lay down the law so what happens is in a
single mother household and shout out to
the single mothers out there I know it
ain't
easy kids are far likely to be
incarcerated far about to give your a
number out I'm like shout out
to 34 you know I stay away from the
single mothers that's not my thing um
far more likely to do drugs far more
likely to get into you know the father's
job is to keep his daughter off the pole
yeah far more likely to do sex work far
more likely to have suicide situations
going on um it's just infinitely worse
so if the goal of the modern day
feminism is to tear down the pat
patriarchy and have this modern day
matriarchy I just want to know what the
world would look like when boys are not
actually turning into men you know men
are supposed to be protectors providers
being present for their woman
understanding how inter seexual Dynamics
work not turning out to be modern-day
Dylan mulany it should be super
concerning that men are not being taught
to be men anymore or boys aren't being
taught to be men anymore and it's being
frowned upon to do what's your basically
instinct used to doing as a man
wrestling fighting being tough standing
up you know standing up to Authority
toxicx exactly that is all known as
toxic masculinity so and what's
happening is that young boys are being
indoctrinated to the lgbtqia a mafia
one-third of men under 30 have not had
sex for a year they're on their phones
Scott Dr Scott Galloway did a whole
dissertation about the scariest people
in the world are broke Lonely Boys
sitting home on their phone playing
video games on social media watching
porn just being completely numb to the
world if we want to help the world we
want to you know I believe the children
our future it does start with the boys
yep I agree awesome okay all right next
story we want to go to is uh the math
for buying a home no longer makes sense
these charts show you why Vinnie very
important pay attention to this next
part here we go here we go again all
right so um The Surge and mortgage rates
now at around 7% has driven up average
average monthly payments in us up 52%
higher than the average apartment rent
52% higher and even higher premiums in
major Metro areas like Seattle Austin
and Texas where it's over
175% damn before the Federal Reserve
began aggressively raising rates a
monthly housing budget of $2,000 could
buy a home valued at over $400,000 now
with current rates that same budget
would only afford a home valued at
$295,000 or less despite Rising rates
home prices have continued to
climb with the national media existing
home price reaching approximately
$392,000 in October the highest ever for
that month and dating back to 1999 this
makes home ownership increasingly Out Of
Reach for many Americans Adam look man
this is something that I've been saying
for years that homeownership is
completely overrated and overpriced I've
been saying that for years I've been
here for here's the freaking math and
it's only only getting worse now with
that being said if you have kids and you
have a family and you want to have a
school district and you want to have
equity in your home totally understand
the premise of why you're going to want
to look to buy a house I get it but
there's a large contingency of young
people especially those under 30 it
would make zero sense for you to buy
whatsoever scroll up here so they can
see the image on here I've been saying
this for years that that buying is
overrated when it just do the math when
it comes down to taxes Insurance
maintenance cost upkeep all that stuff
homeowners association nuclear bunker
downs but since Co it's become
completely unrealistic for anyone that
is basically looking to buy a house
that's crazy right there okay it is sky
Rob are we showing that chart it's
important for people to see cuz you have
to see this and I'll say this and I
think I we we covered this a few months
ago when we really this this numbers
really started coming out in 47 of the
top 50 metros it's not even close
meaning in every major city in America
it's not even a unfathomable whether you
should be renting or buying the three
cities top 50 major metros where it kind
of make more sense to buy AR in
Birmingham Alabama Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania and I believe Detroit if
you're not living in any of those three
cities you're going to need to take a
hard look at renting cuz that's probably
where the better Adam was there was
there a concerted effort to make it like
that what the hell is going on not
supply and demand brother during covid
everyone rushed gold mine to basically
the Gold Rush everyone buy houses there
wasn't enough houses out there they
haven't built enough houses where the
whole um supply chain was off the off
the RoR uhhuh Tom there's just not
enough supplies there so real real quick
Adam said something between the lines
that he mentioned he mentioned taxes and
insurance when you add property taxes to
this this red line gets higher when you
then add the insurance I don't mean that
renters insurance a lot of people people
have renders Insurance when they leasee
that's prudent but there's also the
homeowners insurance where you're
insuring not only the liability of
somebody slipping and falling on your
driveway but the structure itself and
the insurance is not cheap this space
goes up higher well wait a minute wait a
minute if I'm renting a house doesn't
the owner have to pay property tax
doesn't the owner have to pay that isn't
that kind of built into my lease or rent
yes it is but you're renting from
someone that's got a 3% mortgage and
they bought the house years ago so their
property tax basis is lower and it means
that blue line doesn't move the red line
is even worse and Adam mentioned it in
his summation of all the other costs
that go with home ownership that red
line is even higher when you add the
property tax and the insurance on it and
now every five years put a $55,000
maintenance on it you painted the house
there's a you're in the midwest there is
hail you had to do things for your roof
an air conditioner went out and the
condenser you had to be replaced the
argument for renting is very attractive
right now by the way did you see this
chart check this out percentage of new
homes below, 1400 ft before when
Builders Vinnie were Building Homes
these investors were building homes for
renters the average size home they would
build was 1,400 square feet or less okay
today Builders are like there's no money
in that so I don't want to build any,
1400 foot home so look at this 1976
around 36 37% of new constructions for
new homes was 37% then it went to 40%
we're under 1,400 squet homes every year
since 1982 it's gone dropped look what
it is today 7% we went from 40% of new
construction for homes being under, 1400
sare ft to now at 7% simply because
Builders are sit they're saying and this
is from US Census Bureau it's not like
this is a article from uh realtor.com
what what's the moral of the story with
this
meanwhile guess who's picking up all the
uh properties under, 1400 F feet guess
who's buying them up black rock is
buying them up weird because black rock
is going to own they're going to have a
monopoly in renting they're paying
premium they're buying $250,000 uh
condos and houses and they're paying
them $300,000 like don't worry about it
I'll pay $50,000 more it's okay I'll
overb it's okay long term everyone has
to flow through US wow they're going to
control the rent Market the way they're
going right now and Builders are not
interested in building homes that are
less than 1,400 feet if I can just add
one thing something that I always talk
about is that the American dream the
people say the American dream is dead
the American dream is dead I believe
that the American dream is not dead I
believe it is Alive and Well I believe
that is just just changed what do I mean
back in the day the American dream was
that you would go live in the suburbs
have a nice house in the suburbs pick
white picket fence two-car garage 2.2
kids a dog and a cat bingo bango there
it was nice School District Two cat Poss
two cats but what happened is now these
major uh Urban centers have been built
whether it's New York whether it's Miami
whether it's Chicago whether it's Dallas
whether it's La what have you people
have moved out of the suburbs into the
cities okay you no longer need the big
house you can just have an apartment you
no longer need the two cars you can just
Uber I know that's something we
discuss we know that people aren't
banging as much these days they're only
having 1.2 kids not 2.2 kids people are
waiting longer to get married people are
waiting longer to have kids so what's
the what's the point here for the young
people out there that don't have kids
family house all that stuff like that
I've said this a million times before
I'll say it again the key to Financial
Freedom is low overhead and high
flexibility you might get a job
somewhere you might move somewhere you
might not be able to afford a car three
years ago the average car payment in
America for a new car was 550 now it's
close to $ 750 rent which was $1,500 now
it's $2,200
everything's more expensive so what can
you do do you keep doubling down on
what's making you broke or do you do
something completely vastly different
from what you've always done that also
includes college that also includes debt
that also includes credit card debt auto
payments mortgages debt debt debt debt
debt stay debt free stay flexible keep
your cost low and you a couple weeks ago
on on my podcast I covered rent versus
buy and some of these statistics and one
of the things I said as I said is Once
Upon a Time rent was like a dirty word
it's to say oh you're a renter of it was
negative now I say do not think of
yourself that way think of yourself as
being Capital efficient think of
yourself of being enabled think of
yourself of being ready to respond to a
bad economy if your job causes you to
relocate think of yourself as being
flexible it is think of it as a positive
term because you're making a good
decision and don't get conned into
stepping into a purchase that stretches
you and pinches you if you can do it
when you get to a per certain time and
make a prudent purchase with your your
income the income of your partner
whatever you have there great but do not
think of yourself less and apply that
word rer in a negative way you know
years ago Denver posted a story on me in
their business section they put in the
cover it was uh uh if you type in Denver
Post by David I'm wearing this orange
sweater that till today I wish I
wouldn't have worned but I you know I
did it and it was a risk I took look at
that look at that right there wow look
at that guy right there wait can you
zoom in are those are those
True Religion jeans look at those je
your Bel bottoms are killing it's out of
control bottoms are killing it is this
the 7s what
bottom he's he's hiding his boots the
the title of the story is amazing home
buying go with cold clear logic and rent
this is what you're by the way when did
I write when when was this interview
done can you see what October 18th of
2013 all my birthday 10 years ago that's
crazy happy birthday pbd oh man October
I didn't even know was on that day but
so yeah this has been going on it
allowed me to be flexible it allowed me
to move it allow we love this house
titico and Dylan were born I think in
this house and the other house you want
to laugh look what I say it's said I
sold the American dream exactly can you
zoom in right there that's the size of
my apartment right there you're so
funny can I add one thing to this yeah
Tom you did the cost benefit analysis
and broke it down and you said basically
you know the home uh renting has been a
dirty word I always say that the fact
that the Realtor Association has done a
great job marketing you're wasting money
you're just throwing money away you're
missing the American dream exactly it it
all comes under one caveat one super
important caveat so if it cost $3,000 to
buy and it cost 2,000 to rent it all
comes down to what you're doing with
that extra $1,000 that's that's exactly
what I did that's what made me a
millionaire is that every single month
that I was renting I took ,000 extra
dollars pumped that into my 401k pumped
that into index funds bought Bitcoin
whatever it was if you're just taking
that extra money and spending it cuz I
have extra money you're going to end up
broke pennes homeless cuz you don't have
home equity well here's what you got to
know if you do go to the bar without
them yes you a mind to drinks that's
true want to whisper to everybody you're
going to be buying that's true not
buying drinks but Adam will cover the
valet that's what a sweet guy always
always will get the valet and you don't
buy the drinks when you own the bar
brother all right so here we go next one
Alex Jones and Elon Musk after a 5-year
ban off of Twitter and x five year ban
he is finally reactivated after Paul
Elon run so Elon mus has reinstated
conspiracy theorist this is the NBC
story Alex Jones's X account formerly
Twitter after a 5-year ban Jones has
been uh had been banned in 2018 and for
violating Twitter's abuse of behavior
policy Alex Jones that previously spread
false claims uh that San Elementary
School
shot elementary school shooting was a
hoax leading to harassment and threats
against the victim's family sanuk's
victims relativ Sue Jones winning A1
half billion dollar judgment against him
musk's decision to reinstate Jones has
Spar controver controversy with musk
stating that permanent bands should be
extremely rare Elon Musk asks Alex Joan
about Sandy Hook and this is what it
sounds like if you have this while they
did this it was at 60,000 by the time it
was done there was 120,000 people live
listening to this spaces go for Rob I
think I think at least the medium answer
um I I look I guess people just want to
know like obviously it it would be like
heartless and cruel to deny a a a a
school shooting of children um or to
attack the parents uh or or anyone who
is involved it it it seems that that
that would be you know
just incredibly mean and cruel frankly
so it's sort of uh that's that's I think
you know what a lot of people are are
upset about or at least they they think
that is the reason to be upset about um
and you know uh if that were true I
think would rightly rightly be you know
upet with
you yes yes sir well please let me then
just tell you what really happened okay
and and if you want me to send you a
dossier with clips and videos and
articles I mean post it to your account
you know um yes sir I will that so so
let me let me tell you what happened I'm
a guy that didn't go to college me a few
years Community College I started out
whole story this goes for about 10
minutes Rob right in it he says look
five years ago I went on uh uh uh this
is quoted somewh he says I went on Joe
Rogan podcast and I apologize I went on
Patrick M David podcast and I apologize
and he's he's saying all this stuff on
the on
the you know what he did and then you
know at the end others get on they keep
asking asking the question they keep
asking question there sometimes it got
heated you know there was even Andrew
Tate getting on with musk it was just a
very fascinating Twitter spaces uh uh
that took place with the conversations
but for some of you that are watching
this I got a question for you rob maybe
maybe let's do this would you like to
see us do a live at our next you know
pbd podcast live with Alex Jones and
maybe a couple guests if you would like
to see that happen text the word pod to
3103 41132 text the word podcast to 3103
41132 Rob can you put that in chat and
comment section if you have any interest
in us doing a live live podcast at our
5990 live club and afterwards maybe some
of you guys getting a chance to meet
Alex and ask him questions that you may
have at the Cigar Lounge but Tom what do
you think
with Alex now being back one move Wise
from Elon good move bad move and two
would do you think the people on the
left are sitting there saying how the
hell can you give this guy the mic back
for him to start talking and you know
spreading his thoughts and ideas and
opinions that he has well I have a
remarkably succinct point of view here
number one putting him back on is good
for free speech number two it scares the
hell out of Democrats who want to
suppress the voices and control the
narrative especially in election season
but number three I think um him coming
back on and him giving kind of a half
apology I mean you look at the guys on
the Allen pod they were split uh Sachs
and kelanis went back and forth on X one
of them very concerned saying that was
not an apology dude that was not
sufficient and the other guy said hey
you know he gave us a story and he kind
of laid it out there and they kind of
went and I think that's the that that's
sort of the voice of America on Alex
Jones or some of us out there that say
you know that really wasn't quite an
apology and the fact that it took him 5
years to get here and and you really
cornered him you did a good job on the
podcast I thought with Alex Jones W five
years ago yeah I'm not saying he was
upset on me I know he was and I'm not
saying it because you're sitting here
because we've been friends for 15 years
legitimately I thought that you
proceeded the argument in the right way
to Corner him and because he needed to
be cornered because he was refusing to
really engage and talk and dialogue and
kind of cop to what he did and so that's
what I think I think this is good for
free speech I think Elon just scared the
hell out of the liberals who want to
suppress voices about I'm willing to let
voices go and they'd be like ah no and
then Alex Jones you know I I see how
people are feeling there half of them
are saying hey I think that's enough of
an apology and they're not enthusiastic
they're saying okay I think that's
enough of apology I'm not giving him a
free ride but okay he came to the
microphone and other people saying not
enough I I think obviously and Adam you
said this before just about Americans
love a Redemption Story I mean 5 years
that's a long time we all make mistakes
I think we all get caught up in this in
this thing where people think like
especially if you're a Christian you're
supposed to be like I'm Jesus Christ no
I'm going to make mistakes I've seen
people in chat be like oh a guy that
says this this and this but he's a
Christian yeah hold on I didn't say I'm
Jesus I make mistakes I make a lot of
mistakes I think a to take a step back
what Elon has done and I say this a lot
people need to realize what this guy did
for Humanity for speak because those two
twin brothers were on there too Brian
and uh what's it called kenin they're
boy they're they're left they're de
they're hate Trump hating but to have a
forum where we could all speak cuz
that's the problem that we're out right
now two-headed narrative machine what
they are yeah no 100% but I the beauty
of that photo right there Tom is elon's
letting everybody speak nobody's
speaking over each other it's a a forum
where we could all talk but to have uh
you know some like Twitter what three
years ago four years ago they would
block you they take you down if you said
anything that went against their
narrative you would never see that that
would never ever ever happen today if
Elon didn't buy uh Twitter yeah period
I'll add this about Alex Jones some of
the worst things that you could do to
somebody is just dismiss them as oh
they're crazy oh they're just absolutely
wild they don't know what the hell
they're talking about being dismissive
and just dismissing somebody because of
one thing that they said that may or may
not have been wrong I think is very
dangerous now was Alex
wrong Alex Jones absolutely 1 million
per wrong about Sandy Hook yes and he'll
pay the price for that forever literally
but was he right about a lot of
that people were like this guy's wild
he's a conspiracy there is he's crazy
turns out he kind of actually knew some
things that he's talking about the
globalists are coming for you he
predicted did you see the video about
him he said 911
joean said Alex Jones gave me chapter
and verse on Epstein Island 5 years
before it broke yeah and then what was
the thing he went to in California the
whole uh what was the thing Rob Bohemian
Grove Bohemian Grove whatever's going on
real it's real so the the worst thing to
do is just dismiss someone like crazy
what's the point I think it's a great
move by Elon musos bringing him back um
you know I I always side with free
speech I tend to be a free speech
absolutist even if it hurts your
feelings Welcome to the real world where
I sort of draw the line is when it's
inciting violence or I don't know maybe
condoning genocide sort of drawing the
line right there but other than that I
think El uh I what he just said
condoning genocide so universities P MIT
pen MIT in Harvard you know it's okay
what they're doing with that but then
God forbid this guy says something oh
you know what no let's Sue $1.5 billion
so what if what if all these uh people
go around and they decide to sue the
professors or the principles or the
presidents of these three universities
for a couple billion dollars hey you're
inciting violence it's C in people's
lives what about that what about if we
do something like that would that have
the same Merit I don't know but look
welcome back Alex uh don't be surpris if
we um depending on the interest there is
out there with us having uh Alex on a
live live where some of you guys will
get a chance to see him live not just on
the podcast but live like in in flesh in
person talking maybe some of you guys
will get chance to ask him questions
again text the word podcast to 31034
11132 text the word podcast to 310 3411
32 next is Trump says he'll be a
dictator only on day one if he was
elected and people are losing their
minds okay um here we go so Fox was Sean
had and he tried to serve Trump a
softball question asking him if he would
ever abuse his power as president and
seek retribution against those who have
wronged him instead of merely not in his
head and agreeing that he will be
pleasantly Democratic Trump went for the
controversial reply except on day one a
stun Hannity recoiled Trump pointed at
him and laughed look he's going crazy
except for question mark Hannity asked
with a quiver in his voice except for
day one I want to close the border and I
want to drill drill drill that's not
retribution Hannity said I'm going to be
you know he keeps we love this guy he
says you're not going to be a dictator
are you
I said no no no other than day W we're
closing a border and we're drilling
drilling drilling after that I'm not a
dictator so when you hear something like
this by the way this is the clip go and
play this clip here and see what hann's
reaction is going to be because the
media has been focused on this and
attacking you yeah under no
circumstances you are promising America
tonight you would never abuse power as
retribution against anybody except for
day one except for he's going crazy
except for day one meaning
I want to close the border and I want to
drill that's not that's not
retribution I got I'm going to be I'm
going to be you know he keeps we love
this guy he says you're not going to be
a dictator are you I said no no no other
than day one we're closing the border
and we're drilling drilling drilling
after that I'm not a dictator okay that
that sounds to me like you're going back
to the policies when you were president
because the me reaction Tom so here's my
reaction
the media loves this because he gives
them something to do in in kind of a you
know the the current season Ren he gives
them a story it gives them something to
push it gives them a trump button to go
after that's why they like it let's look
at the truth look at what every single
president does on day one what do they
do they ERS exactly they sit at that
small desk most of them well yeah Biden
B and there's underwear no but go go
look at the pictures they sit at this
small desk and it's a historical desk
piece of furniture and they get people
in a semicircle behind them and they sit
there and they sign executive orders ah
the abortion ban gone you know Drilling
in the in the anoir gone aera aera a
it's our own guys that's what they do
and there's the picture there it is
there's that historical piece of
furniture where they sit and they sign
this and you see them that is a folder
either for a bill or an executive order
and they celebrate that on day one every
president does it that's what he's
talking about I'm going to close the
border with an executive
and drill Dr Drill think V it that's
what he's saying but people love to jump
so what is he signing there Tom just
destroy
America right there on the economy
open the border and ruin everything
that's what he's writing Vinnie you
could find the same picture of the last
five presidents Guess what at that desk
little I agree but what was the
difference between what Trump was
writing and what this idiot is writing
and look at she has no idea how to read
say read if you want to think of it that
way then they remember we're supposed to
pass bills back and forth but the
executive order is a loophole and so
where every president is a dictator for
a couple hours on his first day signing
executive orders look to our friend uh
Donald Trump I just friendly piece of
advice dude you could Runway Landslide
this thing against sleepy Joe Biden if
you just be normal don't say things like
yeah I will be a dictator on day one you
know what the media will do
they'll eliminate the day one part and
then they'll have qu quote unquote
Donald Trump I will be a dictator do you
think he planned that Adam you think he
planned that he was in the moment and
he's being funny but that's my point I I
don't think being Vinnie you're a
comedian you know I know you know a lot
of comedians I don't find anything funny
about presidents of the United States
joking haha about being dictators this
isn't Putin's Russia this isn't she
China this is freaking America all Trump
has to do is be freaking normal for nine
more months and he will Landslide Joe
Biden but no he's going to go out there
and promote being a dictator and do
weird sh you think that's going to hold
on that's if these 91 indictments that
they have on this guy whatever the hell
all these charges on this guy stick I
would have I think he's being funny but
the same token I the dictator should
have did did you laugh said
dictator he's hilar we play that last
time Adam guess what if they let if the
active cheating active election
interference that the left is doing as
we speak this guy's being funny he's
being funny and he's saying and he said
it right out loud so he said the border
the border and drill drill drill this is
a campaign thing because he's ring up
his troops
Adam car M daddy is dead he died like a
a dog we love dog beautiful dog
beautiful I agree with Adam I I I'll
wrap it up in just five words I agree
with Adam wow guys this is oh my God
agree with Adam is forward you have to
say
unfortunately I got you no I agree
unfortunately Trump is going to be a
dictator big deal just you know we do
live in a democracy all to no big deal
but I will say this you're right all he
has to say is I will lead the greatest
democracy in the world and on day one I
tell what I've got some executive orders
around the border and drilling he says
that it's different so easy to do
because here's what's going to happen
listen I I know that you believe that
Michelle Obama's going to run and that
she's a man I didn't say none of that I
said she might be running I I I still
believe that Joe Biden is going to be
the nominee to the democrat's Peril
nonetheless I hope so but what's going
to happen is you're going to have Barack
and Michelle Obama campaigning out there
continue our Legacy you already have
Hillary Clinton fundraising as we speak
I believe there's a story about that you
know Hollywood's going to get involved
you know the activists are going to get
involved and you know this is going to
be a neck and neck race versus sleepy
Joe and self acclaimed dictator Donald
Trump let me explain something all I'm
recommending is for Donald Trump trying
to scare to be normal Adam he's a
freaking comedian he's funny by the way
and if that's the case and and if if
guess what if they see that Trump is
winning and you're seeing Obama and all
them stumping for him I wouldn't be
shocked if that movie comes to life and
they do have a Cyber attack from China
but this is this is Donald Trump's
personality Rob can you play when people
are like we have beat this story to
death else look at this dictator talking
about when Joe Biden your boy said that
he was going to take him behind the
school and beat his ass this is what
Donald Trump the comedian said this is
the dictator I think he's in bad shape
physically do you remember when he said
I'd like to take him behind the barn if
he took me behind the barn and I went
like like
this believe look at that dictator look
how funny that dictator is that is so
freaking fun that was hilarious Donald
Trump and he's hilarious so don't take
it serious I'm just that Vinnie I get it
you're like tripling down on Maga I get
it I'm letting you know I never I never
triped down clearly you are brother but
the point is I love America the whole I
love America too not as much as Donald
Trump does you don't love him as much as
Donald Trump look what he's look what
they done the premise of America Vinnie
is that you're we don't have dictators
here we don't have love with the
dictator he it was a you think he's
going to Adam do you know what a
dictator is Vinnie Xi Jinping is a
dictator you think Donald Trump is going
to be a dictator really no but my point
is say what he's busting balls but the
media is going to take this he
doesn't give a Adam they're going
to go against Adam he could say I love
Jesus Christ you know what they're going
to say he's racist he only likes like
give me they would say he loves a
conspiracy theory yeah exactly anything
he says they're going to go against him
so he either way I know you don't
I know you don't watch what's going on
on CNN and the rest of
the I'm just I'm letting you know
there's another world out there other
than the bubble you're living in at this
point I'm letting you know the whole
narrative is that he's just seeking
retribution he's basically filled with
vengeance is Rage and revenge and he's
going to be a dictator I don't believe
the DI so him doubling down on that
doesn't help him win soccer moms in the
Midwest you know women Independence
those are the people he needs to win
dictator talk doesn't help him I'm just
letting you know I know Adam guess what
even joking they jump on it exactly but
guess what I'm saying he goes off the
cuff this is not a planned thing but
guess what be ready Adam cuz if he does
win it's going to be four years of funny
ass like that watch all right let's
go to the next story here so while we're
on this let's talk about what Wall
Street Journal just said about Nikki
Haley Wall Street Journal poll Nikki
Haley leads Biden by by 17 and Trump
leads by four okay so if you want to go
to the story Rob uh Haley a hypothetical
101 matchup with President Biden
currently has a remarkable 17-point lead
51-34 of course in order for that
matchup to happen haly would have to
beat former president Trump to the
Republican primary and the most recent
polls still show her trailing in the
contest by 40 points or more the survey
gives Trump a four-point advantage over
Biden 47- 43 it even finds that Trump if
Trump were convicted of a felony he has
been charged with 91 felony counts in
four criminal
prosecutions he would still only Trail
Biden by a single point the poll puts
Governor Ronda santz debt even with
Biden 45 to 45 so Haley ahead by 17
Trump ahead by four the santis tied Tom
thoughts well suddenly suddenly The Wall
Street Journal coverage of our political
structures sounds a lot like Brazil and
bolsonaro and the guy that was there
that was in prison and got out of prison
it sounds like driving the Brazil
election you you you Pat and I know a
lot about that one um we've dove into it
and I've learned a lot about it but
what's Happening Here I find this I have
a I have a little I'm going to sound
like Vinnie here like maybe I've got a
little you're welcome Tom thinking below
the the surface here I think it's very
interesting that the Wall Street Journal
you know publishes this and all the
establishment billionaires start lining
up behind Haley see she could beat this
guy by 17 points she's had some
establishment billionaires and defense
people lining up behind her the last
couple weeks and I um I I find it kind
of interesting that that happens at the
same time a poll like this comes out and
it almost bifurcates it because it says
look even Trump is convicted he loses by
a point and dantos is even she's our
girl and I just think there's a little
bit of a little bit of establishment
stuff going on here in the Republican
party when is the Iowa caucus by the way
do we have a date on that is that in
January I think January what January
21st or
something yeah that that's going to be a
Telltale sign of where this all goes
obviously Trump is the favorite right
now January 15th so we're literally one
month away from the first votes being
casted do we have results of what's
going on in Iowa initial polls right now
but obviously Trump is the favorite but
we'll see what happens with Nikki Haley
there I think it I think Trump's 20 and
then yep all right but that's in Iowa or
is that the national average you see
that jump when he said you see that jump
when he said dictator P now New
Hampshire Nikki's got Dan santis covered
in a half but in Iowa Dan santis has
been focusing everything on Iowa this is
a result he hit 99 counties he's working
his ass off in Iowa and hoping that an
Iowa win creates this momentum for
donors and campaign support nationally
it's not gonna once he gets to um New
Hampshire and South Carolina the gigs up
and he's in trouble who's in trouble D
santis he's already in trouble but the
point is if he pulls out the second
plate finish it says see I'm the choice
and if this guy is so damaged that he's
not on the ballot I'm your guy that is
exactly what the sis is trying to to do
right here that's all it is I'm not
endorsing I'm just saying that's the
that's the play that they're running not
that I I still believe that Trump's
going to be the nominee I still believe
that Biden's going to be the nominee
you're going have to actually show me
some actual proof not just madeup
stories to be anything other than Trump
Biden however 17 points Nikki
Haley okay that's not a light number
here and we know that Trump's ceiling if
you just want to look at the last two
elections and look at actual numbers is
47% maybe 44 all right so the margin 4
you're right I'm AG at the 47 I'm saying
I held four fingers UPN Biden got to
what 49 in 2020 you know right now he's
pulling at 43 but to see Nikki Haley
with 17 points there's something going
on there with Nikki gen do you you
genuinely think Joe Biden's going to be
their front runner genu in your heart of
hearts you think they're going to pick
him I'm just I'm looking at I'm just
asking at what I'm seeing with my eyes
no CU you're saying we're going to come
up with some random thing I mean Hunters
all over the news right now they're
actually giving him a which is shocking
normally they would protect the out
of him Joe Biden's name is involved in
there a lot you don't think that they're
biting their time at him then when the
time is right they're like oh his name
was involved you were I mean we're not
hold on stop stop have you changed from
a week ago you still think Biden's a
nominee right
yeah I I'll give the disclaimer I think
it's a very weak candidate but I have
not seen anybody jump in yet right and
then like just use your eyes correct
nobody else has declared so until
someone does something I'm just going to
go what's in front of my face and I'm
I'm unchanged Vinnie I've said Biden
steps aside at the Convention as a
superdelegates move and all of this
stuff that you're talking about now is
just the fire under the kettle and they
they stir the pot and he's gone at the
convention so you agree with what I'm
saying then who steps in you're your
slick back hair Bo Gavin Nome was going
to be the guy let me tell youi we can
talk about this on another podcast and
and dive into the probability very
interesting that Hillary's in the you
guys better pray that Joe Biden runs why
pray why cuz Gavin Newsome would smoke
Donald Trump dude let me explain
something you better pray if he is the
President we like K kiss your ass I
would not vote for Gavin Nome I'm
letting you know he would smoke Trump I
don't know I don't know about that look
at his hair he's in bed with OPC yeah I
mean he you don't think Gavin Newsome
would smoke Trump one way you know why
that relationship with China pays off
and they do some nefarious to
the country 100% yes I agree something
would have to happen that relationship
is sus is f is Gavin Nome that doing
that with China if that doesn't send
alarm Bells off in your head then
there's something wrong with you who the
hell is he to go there and then them
come here and give them the Royal
Treatment when they're here look I'm no
fan of Nome but I also acknowledge the
fact that that guy on the surface very
attractive candidate okay on the surface
and he is such a little weasel when it
comes to debating staff corre ad that he
will a governor he will make Trump look
governor of a of a state that people are
fleeing by the the freaking hold on hold
on let me finish my point is hanging out
with a real dictator an actual dictator
that kills his own people that has work
concentration camps that's who you need
to worry about not Trump joking with
freaking Hannity with his with his
freaking part in his hair Vinnie I heard
you the eighth time the thing that I
think we're saying here Tom you have a
little attitude today Pat do you see I
feel it did you see that this is the
second timein you must be saying some
ridiculous for Tom to get upset
with you no he's saying I'm repeating it
maybe you to check yourself getting Tom
you sound like a DI Tom is annoyed by
you s a DI that Gavin Nome is the kind
of slick politician that can work his
way in and win an election in the modern
media world that we live today with the
combination of social online everything
else he is exactly the corrupt actor
that can get elected yeah you you better
hope that Biden uh Health as well if you
want Trump to win me and you we're
betting guys Adam it's not going to be
Biden it's either listen take this to
the bank it's going to be Nome or
Michelle Obama or or sleeper Hill so
that means that means you're encouraging
Trump to lose I'm not what do you mean
I'm encouraging I in my humble opinion
either of those two would smoke Trump no
I'm saying Adam I'm being a no I'm not
hoping nothing I'm being a realist
you're saying you think it's clear
because Joe Biden's in you're saying
we're going to come up with some random
thing I'm telling you I think it's going
to be Gavin Newsome or Michelle Obama or
a sleeper Hillary you should pray for
Biden's Health if you want Trump to win
is what I'm saying oh wow this is what
it looks like now correct whoops really
whoopsie Haley is third Nome is fourth
Oh weird RFK fifth Michelle oh s
Michelle is beating Ron the San go lower
go lower to see who it is next Camala
Vic Joe Mansion 80 to1 Elizabeth War all
of the
candidat all of the candidates listed
100 to one just so you guys know
Vinnie's in that Community thank you cuz
I'm by the way by the way you know whose
name is officially off that list that
was up there Hillary Clinton Hillary
Hill she's no longer on this list do you
see her there right because she was on
that Hillary so but okay um fiery
podcast covered a lot of stuff um from
Obama's movie to um lots of other things
go watch it should go watch that movie
Tom had too much attitude I'm sorry
these guys fight afterwards over you're
a great have a great day we will do this
again Thursday take care everybody bye-
bye bye-
bye